soy hijo de padre blanco
y madre negra
soy hijo de un profesor universitario y
una analfabeta
soy hijo de un barrio invasión y un
barrio de interés social
soy el fruto el resultado del amor de
dos aparentemente contrarios
bueno también puede decir que soy hijo
de la destrucción y la transformación de
esta ciudad medellín
soy músico desde los 3 años ni me lo
recuerdo compongo desde los 8 años de
edad
y pues acabo de revelarles lo que corre
por mi sangre y adn y tal vez por ese
motivo siempre en mi música de manera
consciente o inconsciente
he buscado
puentes conexiones maneras
entre diferentes ideas realidades a
veces contrarias o antagónicas también
pero como como lo he logrado
como es sobrevivido a ese trabajo a ese
mestizaje sonoro a esa fusión a esa
mezcla interminable de gestos musicales
instrumentos ritmos melodías
bueno hoy tire
elementos fundamentales
el primero
conocer
conocer los ingredientes con los que vas
a trabajar
no amarlos no necesariamente amarlos
pero si conocerlos
segundo
entender los límites
hasta donde se pueden encontrar
elementos ritmos
melodías
y donde definitivamente en el encuentro
de los ritmos o dos géneros musicales
definitivamente no hay negociación en
qué elementos no sucede
y el tercero
el respeto a todas las músicas
la música es el reflejo de un pueblo de
una sociedad
y así
como tienes el respeto
por esas personas que la habitan tienes
que tener el respeto por sus sonidos por
sus combinaciones musicales
como lo he logrado
como logrado ese mestizaje sonoro y no
solamente lograrlo
también llevarlo a lo más alto de la
música del mundo
y poder transmitirlo de una manera
positiva
vamos a ver vamos a escuchar unos
ejemplos como se ha hecho
tu mano para cuando te parió
y te quito
mi corazón
[Música]
no te digo para más
corazón
ya no te diré ahora más el mundo
para marí el cuarteto latinoamericano
tremenda experiencia
recibo la llamada de un compañero un
colega mexicano y me dice cuánto te
queremos invitar a que escribas una
música
unas arreglos unas versiones de unas
canciones del siglo 10 de la cultura
sefardí
y yo un momento yo soy el del piano el
de la salsa el tropical lo sabemos pero
sabemos también que lo que tú hagas no
ha sucedido en mil años en esas
canciones
fue un reto
pero encontré algo encontré un diálogo
que esta música y mi vida personal
convergía se encontraba se conectaba
cuando empecé a escuchar estas canciones
me di cuenta que estas canciones siempre
hablaban de la despedida
por toda la cultura sefardí está y todo
lo que significa este pueblo en el mundo
y en la historia siempre hablaba de
despedidas pero estas canciones
particularmente hablaban de el que se
queda no el que se va
sino el que se queda
el del tedio no el que está viviendo la
aventura sino el que todos los días se
despierta a ver si su amado vuelve y
encontré
como un chispazo en mi cabeza
la vida de mi madre la vida de mi madre
que un día mi hermano salió de la casa y
nunca volvió y como mi madre cada día se
sentaba a la misma hora a esperar que mi
hermano apareciera
si teníamos algo en común como el disco
se llama y lo invisible teníamos un hilo
invisible que estas historias estas
canciones de más de mil años de historia
eran totalmente adecuadas para hablar
sobre los desaparecidos
o sobre esos que nunca vuelven a casa
continuemos
y sólo me
[Música]
ah
si me quiere con todo el amor que da
para ti no te di con todas las promesas
sin cumplir con todas las disculpas que
lloré con todos los papeles que pedí
puerto candelaria 20 años trabajando en
puerto candelaria hemos hecho y desecho
todos los ritmos musicales de colombia
hemos probado con todos los instrumentos
con todas las melodías con todo lo que
nos dicen y sentimos que es colombia y
encontramos que colombia no está en esos
instrumentos no están esos ritmos está
en el diálogo entre lo real y lo absurdo
entre la alegría la frustración
entre la esperanza la capacidad que
tenemos de esperanza y también el
talento que tenemos para el error
encontré un diálogo
y así sonaba puerto candelaria
continuemos
[Música]
no no
[Aplausos]
cruz peligrosos
sinfónico cada vez vamos más a unos
lugares más dinamitados siempre me
llaman para esos lugares que me llaman a
hacer una cancioncita normal no siempre
pasan esas cosas
mezclar el rap los maestros del rap de
aranjuez con los maestros de la
sinfónica nacional solo voy a decir algo
para que entiendan el nivel de
complejidad al que estábamos al frente
el primer ensayo se retrasó porque las
personas de la producción no creyeron
que cuando llegaban unos muchachos con
cachuchas así iban a ensayar con la
orquesta sinfónica
eso era mentira ahí había algo extraño
tuvimos que salir a decir si ellos son
los maestros y hoy la sinfónica nacional
los va a acompañar continuemos
[Música]
deja que la música avance bastante
yo quitan
con el disco behind the machine en grupo
por excelencia urbano de nuestro país
orgullo vamos a quitarle lo que se llama
urbano
vamos a despojar lo que sucede en eso
cuando choquibtown se le quita la
máquina lo urbano cuando se le quitan
las luces cuando se le quita el ruido
empieza a sonar el río esa sonar la
noche los animales la selva empieza a
sonar el choco el pacífico es a sonar
colombia
suena bonito pero los directivos de la
casa disquera chocquibtown cuando les
dijimos pero no sea que ustedes quieren
que un disco perdón que un grupo que
suena en las discotecas ustedes quieren
que la gente se siente y tome un vino
mientras los escuchan sí
porque cuando tú quitas la máquina
escucha de la naturaleza y escuchas la
gente continuamos
[Música]
la trópico iban con es de unas se dan
ganas dan ganas de inmediato
el diálogo entre las generaciones las
trópico y van los maestros de la música
colombiana ahí el maestro carlos piña al
lado de nosotros compartiendo sus
experiencias sus conocimientos sobre la
música el diálogo entre las generaciones
sino si perdemos eso vamos a hacer un
futuro vacío siempre que que no tengamos
honrar padre y madre la mejor manera de
decirlo continuemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
si saben qué canciones jaime molina
una canción que siempre la escuchamos en
nuestras fiestas en momentos alegres de
la vida que tal despojar todo eso que
nos da esas ganas de bailar esa alegría
e ir al fondo del significado de la
canción de una canción totalmente
trascendental íntima y profunda que es
hablar de la muerte de un amigo
ese fue el ejercicio
con la filarmónica de bogotá en sus 50
años que celebramos el año pasado y
vamos a terminar con este otro ejemplo
musical
en mi tierra
en mis de más tu dolor
este
si quieres
[Música]
uno de los retos más difíciles de mi
carrera no solamente como músico sino
también como persona como ciudadano en
estas montañas la conmemoración de los
200 años de antioquia hacer una versión
del himno y antioquia que hablara de las
nuevas regiones de antioquia de regiones
que ni siquiera se conocían
tal el descubrimiento que gran cantidad
de personas descubrieron que antioquia
tenía amar
imagínense el reto musical en una de las
piezas que oficialmente en la
institucionalidad nos representa como
cultura un reto el cual fue totalmente
el resultado me llena de emoción han
logrado eso y otras cosas
que sienten las regiones porque no es
desde aquí desde la capital que sienten
las regiones me parece que en el norte
es pues la música me parece que en el
sur me parece que en el urabá no cuáles
son las músicas y cuando te encuentras
que el norte de antioquia se representan
con el vallenato y tú dices un momento
eso es ese es el diálogo eso es
para que la busque para que la música
crezca
así como las sociedades para que la
música crezca se transforme construya se
necesita un diálogo se necesita ese
mestizaje sonoro esa fusión esa mezcla
esos tres elementos que dije
inicialmente qué pasa qué pasaría si los
llevamos a nuestra vida a nuestra
cotidianidad vida a nuestra cotidiana
vida a nuestras grandes preguntas a
nuestros grandes problemas por eso hoy
no vengo a hablarles vengo a dejarles
una pregunta muchas gracias
[Aplausos]